amanecía en kiev cuando se daba la
alerta los disparos tenían como objetivo
este lugar en los suburbios del sur de
la capital dejaron una fábrica de armas
totalmente destruida moscú reivindica la
autoría del ataque
la noche anterior misiles de alta
precisión y largo alcance con base en el
mar alcanzaron una instalación militar a
las afueras de kiev el número y la
escala de los ataques con misiles contra
objetivos en kiev aumentarán en
respuesta a cualquier ataque terrorista
o sabotaje cometido por el régimen
nacionalista de kiev en el territorio
ruso
streeter es para unas declaraciones que
hacen referencia al supuesto bombardeo
de dos pueblos rusos en la frontera con
ucrania pero kiev niega cualquier
responsabilidad en cambio selenski asume
y reivindica el ataque de este buque
ruso el moskova presuntamente alcanzado
por misiles neptune el buque insignia se
hundió en el mar negro visto pocas apps
son los barcos rusos sólo puede venirse
al fondo del mar
moscú niega cualquier agresión pero
reconoció que su buque de guerra se
hundió en el mar negro a pesar de las
versiones contrastantes sobre las
circunstancias de su perdida parece ser
otro revés para rusia en marzo la armada
ucraniana apunto a otro barco clave el
buque de transporte de tropas orsc en el
pueblo ocupado de bird ians que a 80 km
de mariupol